[Music]
this is Major I'm on site I'm going in
you are the first of your kind but
you're not invulnerable maybe next time
you can design me better
[Music]
everyone around me they feel connected
to something
connected to something
[Music]
but aji you were dying
we saved you and now you see the others
[Music]
another minute rest trust me
you know I have a past
I'll find out who I was
everything they told you was a lie who
are you they did not save your life they
stole it
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so ghost in the
shell' drop let's break it down
also let me know the first time you ever
saw a ghost in the shell' so most of you
probably know at least a little bit
about the ghost in the shell' franchise
there are a couple different films
they're basically remakes of the
original 1995 film but that film itself
is an adaptation of manga so if you're
big fan of manga you're a big fan of
anime I would recommend you just
re-watch the first film this live-action
film is basically that story so just as
a general recommendation if you're
looking for an order to rewatch the
original anime before this movie comes
out you can either watch the animated TV
series or the movies so the movie order
you should watch is the ghost in the
shell' 1995 film then ghost in the
shell' 2 then the Laughing Man movie
then individual 11 then stand alone
complex solid States Society and then
the ghost in the shell' new movie but I
would recommend that you just keep it
simple they're all pretty fantastic but
the best is that original 1995 film that
was the one that blew my mind when I saw
for the first time but the watch order
for the TV series is stand alone complex
second gig and then arise so there's
plenty of ghost in the shell' out there
but some of it is a remake of previous
ghost in the shell' so that's why you
should always start with the 1995 film
or at least start with the manga if you
really want to read the manga but the
trailer pretty much explains the broad
strokes it's basically this Westworld
type story where you have the idea of
evolving artificial intelligence in how
scary that can be but you see that she
has this real brain but the fact that
she has so many cybernetic parts leaves
her very open to cyber attacks so like a
lot of 80's 90's computer technology
based stories there's a lot of hacking
that's going on in the movie but you can
kind of see how like the different
characters have various levels of
electronic prostheses there's basically
a big thing in the film so like people
have a lot of robotic parts some people
are fully robots some are mostly robot
which is basically like the major
character she with the exception of her
brain there's like fully cybernetic but
the cool thing here you may have
recognized this is that this is euron
greyjoy here from Game of Thrones
playing but - so I thought that was kind
of fun - spotting
but like a lot of these iconic trailers
scene moments are moments from the
original film like the big action
set-pieces where she like basically it
takes her clothes off and jumps off the
building you can see that they've kind
of made this for a broader audience it's
a little more hardcore he's actually
fully nude in the animated movie
whenever she jumps off the building but
then you have the service droid in the
harem that goes haywire that's right out
of the 1995 film the trailer jumps
pretty quickly into the idea that she's
like slowly starting to experience
something happening with her brain
that's basically the hacking element of
the movie because she's mostly
cybernetic so any digital circuit can be
hacked so thus she's open to the puppet
master who is this figure here but you
know basically the person that's
speaking to her about them stealing her
body so without giving away spoilers
about who he is in how he evolves just
remember like Westworld it's a story
about the evolution of artificial
intelligence like your baby basically
like at the precipice here and during
the movie they address that and if
you're wondering what the song is that's
playing under this it's a version of
Depeche Mode enjoy the silence which
like when you listen to the lyrics does
kind of play into the theme of her kind
of joining this giant digital
consciousness so if you're wondering why
they used it the song was also kind of
written during the period when the manga
was coming out like late 80s early 90s
so it seems pretty appropriate that they
would attach it to a ghost in the shell'
movie but let me know what you guys
think I know a lot of people will be
focusing on Scarlett Johansson is the
major character because she basically
carries the film but there are a lot of
other big characters like the puppet
master and but - I'm really interested
to see your on Greyjoy in this film he's
a really big character in the original
story so just to reiterate if you really
want to watch some ghosts in the shell I
recommend you just start with the 1995
film but let me know what your favorite
ghost in the shell' I haven't read the
manga in a long long time but I usually
do rewatch the film at least once a year
just because it's so awesome
but I just remember encountering this
film around the same time I saw a cure
for the first time which is because they
kind of come from the same aesthetic and
usually like if you have a friend that
introduces you to anime and they give
you a kira they also give you ghost in
the shell' just because they kind of go
hand in hand before you go for the more
obscure stuff put it's just a reminder
the movie is coming out March the
first so it's not gonna be out for a
little while so they'll probably a
couple more trailers so it'll be cool to
see how close they stuck to that
original story but what's gonna happen
later tonight is I'll post my Walking
Dead episode 4 video after it airs so be
sure to subscribe to get that they'll be
new Marvel I was originally gonna do
Deadpool today but then this dropped so
Walking Dead NYX and Deadpool on Monday
got a bunch of Marvel DC stuff happening
in the next couple of weeks just because
there's so much TV and movie stuff
happening where you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my latest
Game of Thrones Season 7 video and you
can click here for that Dave Chappelle
Walking Dead skit thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you